what's up everybody zacky here from geek
culture and today we have another geek
unboxing courtesy of amazon singapore
with their great toy sale that's
happening from the 10th of july to the
24th of july amazon singapore has kindly
given us 500 to spend on their great toy
sale with over 7 000 toys to choose from
and 50 off you're not here for a good
deal
[Applause]
thanks han
now jumping to camera number two you can
see right behind me there's a bulk spot
over there and we're gonna fill it up
with all the toys that we've ordered
well not me i mean they are the ones the
producers behind ordered it i have no
idea
what toys are in so i mean for a
surprise so let's hop to it and today we
have
okay
sorry
small
and we have
abby tell us what is this all about it's
a diamond select toys marvel gallery
venom pvc diorama figure at nine inch
all right we have eddie brock uh that's
becoming venom
i'm guessing this cost
89 id
you are
wrong
it actually goes for 61. and after
discount it's 28 dollars
no way
now if you're a fan of venom i think
this is a very good deal i mean just
look at the sculpting and the details
from the sloppy venom slimy thing
and i mean look at look at look at brock
right such a hunk
right gang
we got oh man all right
back to the future delorean time machine
wow oh let's unbox this and it's um from
factory entertainment
you're right i just like how the box has
the uh license plate you can take a look
here
that's really cool
back to the future
what is this
it's the
flying delorean motion statue
it can move that's why it's called a
motion statue
right when it's just a spring yep
well okay i mean so it's basically a
bubble head
ish kind of thing
but is it electronic or anything like
that do it i don't think there's
batteries i'm guessing this is 15
what fifteen dollars
look this one was sixty six dollars and
it went down to forty six what
[Music]
i think it's something great for the
display it's not the greatest replica
you will see for what it's worth i think
it's a really nice novelty item that you
can display on your shelves
and we have
wolverinos
they call it the
munovarin
it's the manga realization of you're
right wolverine by tamashii nations
oh you could change the blades as well
wow
let's open this up ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
folks
give me a second nope nope
okay there's three different blades
of claws
for wolverine and just look at that nice
gold
design on him
that looks so good
so i'm gonna guess this is
are you sure look at how magnificent the
costume design is and all the
accessories that come with it it's
probably
okay and i put it that way 75 dollars
very very close this discounted price is
actually 79
and that's a drop from 140
so it's literally almost half the price
almost
so you can see that this is a samurai
style inspired
wolverine with three different claws to
choose from so you got the serrated one
you got the classic straight edge one as
well as the
hook blades
so you know like he has this classic
blue and gold metallic finish
as a fan of japanese samurais
i love it it's great
we have another tamashii nation's ronin
boba fett
wow
this is going to be exciting
you have eight different weapons to
choose from so you can pose them as much
as you like
different stances and stuff so let's
open this bad boy up
[Applause]
wow
this one's fire yeah yeah
this is totes soto it's lit
that stuff on the top you have is the
classic katana with the swatch sheath
you have a
japanese inspired ronin-inspired rifle
and daggers and stuff like that as well
and you have different types of
hand variants
for you to pose with as well as a very
cool classic jet pack as well that's
very iconic boob effect and looking at
boba fett himself and his decked out in
the summer armor
very very very cool so let's start
posing him do you want to guess how much
he is
i'm gonna guess it's gonna be the same
price
as wolverine and maybe slightly more
expensive because the star wars
well i'm gonna say
again
about eighty dollars
it's actually cheaper than a wolverine
one this was 66
66 fan bams yeah i'll definitely go for
the star wars collection man and through
some tv magic this is the final form of
boba fett
so you can see he's decked out on his
boots areas all his weapons
got a nice harpoon kunai over here
his katana
his rifle and
his neat little visor thingy that
actually came it actually pops up and
down
it's so satisfying
so we've got two tamashii nations action
figures
from marvel and from the star wars line
so
you can expect the marvel to have
the swords of spider-man black panther
and for star wars there's uh darth vader
stormtrooper as well so now moving on to
the next box
oh
let's generally have a one-tenth scale
pre-painted model kit of thor odinson
yeah it's by
cotton okay
so we are looking at a
limited edition yep you can say that
it's premium yeah so we got his bust so
it looks like he's holding it wow okay i
can see why it's really beautiful it
smells new
but wait till you look at his face and
his beard and his eyes it's crazy
611th
of 3500 and on top of the thor statue
you do get a card of authenticity
so very nice again with the
611 over
statues that you have how well sculpted
this is down to the details of the
textured
armor plates on his legs on his man
thighs
as well as to his
fan braces over here
[Music]
and a gold
just a gold hammer man i'm guessing this
is a collector's item so
i want to say this is about 120 bucks
very close it's actually 111 dollars
right down from 211 so that's a whole as
like 100 discount
toss a coin
what do we have here it's obviously the
witcher
right it's a six inch vinyl figure from
jinx
jigs so this is from uh not the netflix
series this is from the actual witcher 3
game so this is geralt uh from witcher 3
very very iconic character
seen in on netflix he probably played
the games
and this is yeah i've never heard of
drinks before
[Music]
they do have a unique style i mean those
who have collected funko pops i think
you guys can get into this big head
small body
very very very nice
so they do have other characters as well
from what we see they have um some
characters from halo
and minecraft all right
that's cool
i'm guessing this is about same price
maybe 2025 yep it's actually 23. um it's
original price was 50.
oh wow okay so yeah if any of y'all
trying to start a new collection
perhaps uh toys from jinx
could be a very good option
all right well for the books guys we're
done oh i'm out this big and ladies and
gentlemen oh hello
ah what is this tell me
what is that do you want to describe it
to me first i'll give it a shot so okay
so this is supergirl
uh-huh definitely so it's uh i'm
guessing it's from dc direct or disney
or disney
a dc designer series by art jam
um apparently he's really big right tell
me about him
uh yeah he is um jim is an artist from
hong kong and he has like a really huge
following online he has done many things
for like marvel
dc and like stuff and his illustrations
are really good
this is a 15.3 inch statue
and it's based from yes we know artist
stanley arjun lao
sorry that was me
it's all solid one piece
that's all you need to do guys well easy
minor assembly required i'm gonna say
this is gonna be around the hundreds so
140 170
it is actually 106
that's the discounted price
it used to be 156.
so i think for for what it's made and
look at how sturdy it is i think it's
it's pretty worth it considering eyes
from art gym as well
it feels more like ceramic than
polarizing it's not as like soft
as uh for almost a hundred dollars i
think that is a steal i think there's
only one other design that they have on
right now which is harley quinn
um and there's only one left in stock no
so if you guys have seen this video
hopefully it's still around
one more thing to add about this is that
it's a numbered limited edition 226 of 5
000. okay i believe there's one more
god
okay this
this is something i know my boss
all right he will order because he is a
fan of alien any video you see about
alien on our and our youtube channel or
any of our social media postings is
definitely from our boss okay who should
not be named because it's a very shy guy
but what we have is
dorbz
darbs
uh something like jinx and funko pops
they have their own uh vinyl
uh collectible it's actually a glow in
the dark
predator
it's glow in the dark which is exciting
because i've never seen anything like it
okay
how about we turn off the lights man
that's so crazy
this is cool it's a very unique thing
here
right do you want to guess how much it
is ten dollars
oh my god right on the dodge
ten dollars
okay
yeah
this funko's fine
we also have another dorbz
of course what what what will be
predator without alien right thank you
boss
oh
it's really cool i could see why
so yeah another dorps
this cute little
[Music]
alien thingy here
oh
look at his head
do you want to take a guess they are
actually differently priced
how different like drastically different
or like i think it's it's a big
difference
so if that's going for 10 bucks i'm
gonna say this is like
20.
it's actually five dollars oh oh half of
that why are the aliens more like famous
and predator but
oh well
okay okay i would assume because it's
glow in the dark maybe maybe see but
that's the thing though because they're
15 each if you get both of them it's
actually the price of one
mess
you guys are in for a deal guys come on
and last but not least i believe that
it's all right
yeah that is all we have in this
gigantic box
moving on moving on
and last but not least we have the
uh funko pop movies
uh this is a
more like a diorama than the individual
funko pop so this is the banquet room
for ghostbusters with venkman and
spangler capturing slimer which is
totally iconic if you guys haven't seen
it
yeah totally awesome guys
and i'm gonna guess this is going for
[Music]
that's actually closer to the original
price the original price is 60. okay the
offer price is 24. wow
wow
so
that is all we have from the big big box
no no no no wait
what wait a second uh-huh
we got something for you actually for me
yes we burst our budget for you so
that's a classic gc move guys
gotta close our eyes i don't know why i
have to yes
this is a good toy
dude why is it so
what's so tall can i open it now yeah go
ahead it's sucked away
is it shield it's a shield this is
shield yes it's the marvel legends
captain america premium shield
all right man
there we go
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna do this
for the rest of the day
[Music]
so wow it's a one-to-one skill it's
quite heavy isn't it it's heavy yeah
it's funny i think this costs about 200
uh-huh yeah
hundred dollars for this it's 130
wow
well i won't say we call it over budget
i mean
the amazon singapore great thai sir is
happening from the 10th the 24th of july
and with over 7 000 toys to choose from
and up to 50 off you guys know you're
getting a great great deal
wow
would you look at that
[Music]
well
that's all the toys that we wanted to
share with you guys
once again don't forget to snag all
these sweet sweet deals from amazon
before the sale is over
and speaking of which
for your next delivery you might want to
consider doing so with an amazon prime
membership as an amazon prime member
myself i would highly recommend their
services
with amazon prime you get to enjoy free
next day delivery on all domestic orders
with no minimum purchase
this means even if you order only one
item it also gets delivered the next day
for free with no extra shipping costs as
for international orders you only need a
clock 60 dollars to enjoy free delivery
too
what's cool too is that you have access
to prime video and free pc games money
via twitch prime
all these sweet sweet perks come at a
mere 2.99 per month which is cheaper
than a cup of bubble tea
ah thank you mr hen
better yet you guys can try out the 30
day free trial and get yourself some
toys before the still ends so what are
you waiting for
oh
yes
we totally forgot about this
[Music]
that's not gonna fit anyway
you